Now that we've looked at the architecture
of the internet, let's see how you might
connect your personal devices to
the internet inside your house.
Well there are many ways to
connect to the internet, and
most often people connect wirelessly.
Let's look at an example of how
you can connect to the internet.
If you live in a city or a town,
you probably have a coaxial cable for
cable Internet, or a phone line if you
have DSL, running to the outside of
your house, that connects you to
the Internet Service Provider, or ISP.
If you live far out in the country,
you'll more likely have
a dish outside your house, connecting
you wirelessly to your closest ISP, or
you might also use the telephone system.
Whether a wire comes straight from
the ISP hookup outside your house, or
it travels over radio
waves from your roof,
the first stop a wire will make once
inside your house, is at your modem.
A modem is what connects the internet
to your network at home.
A few common residential modems are DSL or
cable which translate the digital
data from your computer
into digital signals to be transmitted
over cable or telephone wires.
From the modem, an ethernet cable will
usually connect to a residential router.
Although today, some service
providers combine your modem and
router together in one box.
Inside your house, you might have multiple
devices from a laptop to a thermostat.
But no matter what kind of devices you
have, your router acts as your home's
central hub that connects all
you devices to the internet.
In order to connect to a router,
you can either hard connect a device with
an ethernet cable, like in the case of a
TV, desktop computer, or game console, or
wirelessly, like for a laptop, phone,
or printer equipped with Wi-Fi.
To review,
everything we've been learning about,
the backbone of the internet is made
up of primary routers, networks, and
typically fiber optic cables
connecting networks around the globe.
Routers and switches create local and
wide area networks.
Modems and routers connect your devices
to the internet service provider,
which connects you to the internet.
And the TCP/IP protocol suite
defines the rules of how
each of these devices
communicate over the Internet.
The Internet has come a long
way since its inception as
a US Defense Department research project.
And most people take for granted how
easy it is to connect information and
people through the Internet nowadays.
But maintaining the pipelines,
protocols, and
technologies that keep the Internet
working is no easy task.
It's also important to note before we go,
that not everyone in
every country has equal access to
this great pipeline of information.
But no matter where you're from, or
what you wish to do on the Internet,
being informed, maintaining standards, and
contributing to the upkeep of the internet
hardware and protocols is our
responsibility as consumers.